joining us now author of the
best-selling book vengeance former
Speaker of the House Fox News
contributor Newt Gingrich mr. speaker
good to see you well it's good to see
you look and I think the president has a
lot to crow about that was pretty
impressive think about how close he is
to getting the tax cuts that will lead
to I think a generation of economic boom
by the way it's I use Ricola and if it
really gets bad you need strong
anti-inflammatories to get the vocal
cords working I use my voice I'll try
and talk more in your favor but you know
look at the statistics I just read off
that's significant economic growth major
corporations now promising billions and
investment factories saved from moving
to Mexico because the president's
involved by himself burdensome
regulation energy independence the house
look they're not perfect I'm not wasn't
exactly happy with repeal and replace
the Senate's getting nothing done mr.
speaker
they haven't even confirmed half of the
the president's nominees well let's see
how the next couple of weeks work out I
think you got first of all if they can
get the tax bill through the Senate that
is a huge victory and erases a lot of
problems second I think they're going to
get between a hundred and 150 appointees
approved between now and Christmas
that'll move judgeships ambassadors
other jobs at a pretty fast pace up
until they leave on Christmas Eve
so I think it'll be a different
appearance will they get this bill done
outside the US do you think the Senate
is gonna get this tax bill done I do yes
I think they will why I think I'm a
native because unlike the whole health
care fight this is a really
straightforward issue do you want the
American people to have more money or do
you want the government to have more
money there are many Republicans
the end who are going to come down for
the government having more money and I
think Rand Paul today had a very fine
article explaining why he was for the
bill and why he hoped others would join
him in being for the bill and I hope
you're going to see I know for example
that Ron Johnson has been very worried
about the small business tax cuts well I
think that's been largely fixed and I
think that the National Federation of
Independent businesses and other folks
who are for the job creators Network
have all come out and said this is a
very good first step for small business
it helps probably 95 percent of the
small businesses in the United States
so there's series of those things coming
down the road that make me feel pretty
optimistic yeah by the way I've had your
same throat issues people think it
really hurts to talk it doesn't right I
mean we're not going to torch you it
just is what it is the vocal cords get
inflamed and they just need to calm down
as all of us but it doesn't hurt I speak
from experience it just makes us think
it hurts yeah I I like the middle-class
tax cuts is necessary the corporate tax
cuts will make us so competitive
we're patreon there may be as much as
four trillion dollars that comes flowing
back in short order to the United States
the steps the president's taken on
energy independence will create millions
of high-paying career jobs I worry about
one thing with the Republican Party
helped me out and that is it seems
reagan dropped the top marginal rates
from seventy to twenty eight percent in
his presidency we doubled revenues to
the government 21 million new jobs
longest period of peacetime economic
growth up to that point in history what
I worry about is out of fear that of the
class warfare rhetoric of the Democrats
that's why we're not cutting taxes
across the board in other words top
twenty percent paid ninety-one percent
of the the tax bill the income tax bill
seems cutting their taxes would be smart
to for everybody and would work like it
worked for Kennedy and Reagan your
thoughts
well it would work but remember if you
cut the corporate rate down to 20%
virtually everybody who's successful is
going to be better off because they own
the stock they own the investments so
this is not exactly anti success I think
the key here is can you package a bill
where you make it very hard to vote no
and that's the whole game here making it
hard to vote no and I think they didn't
want to give the New York Times The
Washington Post you know Nancy Pelosi
and those folks an easy Club to beat him
with I think it probably was the right
decision I can make a good argument
I voted for the Reagan tax cuts I can
make a good argument for cutting
everybody's taxes but the truth is if
this economy booms everybody who's
successful is going to be a lot better
off just because they're gonna be part
of a huge rising tide of economic
opportunity let me ask you about Franken
Conyers that I played that Russert clip
from Meet the Press with Nancy Pelosi
and now she's calling for due process
but only because it's a Democrat I
actually believe in not rushing to
judgment on anybody especially people
that deny charges so and that goes for
John Conyers or anybody else and I
believe in the presumption of innocence
I believe it strongly I think everybody
should and it's proven me right with
Richard Jewell and and Duke Lacrosse and
in Ferguson and with Trump having the
possibility of winning or Baltimore
where the media's gotten it wrong so
many times and my question is here you
see selected moral outrage and then the
issue of defending the Clintons for 30
years comes into play just want to get
your reaction to all of that and what
what you think of this double standard
look we look back some day and realize
we were the generation that had to put
up with the Clintons for our entire life
that may be ending this may all be
coming to a head and it's conceivable
that a year or two from now they will
have disappeared
and finally will be free at last yeah
all right Mr Speaker I like Ricola if
you need my Doctor Who without you these
moments I'll give you the offline I
don't want to be encouraging the use of
medicines because I'm not a doctor and
I'm not gonna play one on TV we hope you
feel better and I would do I would have
talked less I seem to feel better thanks
for being with a speaker Gingrich